happy Thanksgiving everyone now it's a
thursday i usually do my thankful
thursdays today and what better day to
do a thankful thursday then on
thanksgiving now canada birdie
celebrated our thanksgiving we have ours
in october i've already done the turkey
the the pumpkin pie with tons of whipped
cream and the highlight for us was
hating that my mom making these special
pumpkin cookies that he decorated and
hand it out to everybody but it's thanks
hearing from my american friends and i
hope you take time today to reflect on
the year that's been to thank the people
in your life and your business we've had
an impact and yes you may not be where
you want to be yet you know you may have
goals to be here and you're just here
right now you're you're climbing that
path and it may seem like it's it's hard
and long and you're not making momentum
but be grateful for where you are now
right even to get to where you are here
there's a lot of people who've helped
get you there's a lot of people who
believed in you to help get you there
and so take today take five minutes even
just to think about how lucky you are
how grateful you should be for all the
people in your life who helped you get
to where you are now and they will
continue to help you to get to where you
want to be at the end so thank you guys
for watching have a great Thanksgiving
continue to believe and I wanted to
close with some funny clips from one of
my favorite shows America's Funniest
Home Videos
today
don't forget to check out my newsletter
click the link below hi I'm Jason J
reyez fonseka of ra's online com and i
want to say Evan Carmichael's newsletter
is consistent fun inspiring and XD only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period